alive there we go and then it takes a minute to start up for some reason and the
reeflings are about to puke don't puke don't puke baby it's gonna be okay
you're gonna make it reeflings i promise we're gonna we're all gonna make it
together hold strong hold strong for that
right i'll just need to wait until one of them says hi
and then i do my good morning oh someone says hi
reeflings good morning good evening good afternoon reeflings
now i know this isn't my usual stream tame but that's because
i am joined by none other than the beautiful ozzy
i'm joined oh jillie that's your cute introduction
hi i am arisa newnish uh all up by rissa i honestly don't mind pronounce it
however you feel like uh i am a technically
pre-debut uh vtuber but i have been streaming for about three years and i
am staroni's video editor so you know all those magnificent shorts that are
subtitled and edited out the wazoo that's none
other than arisa the complete mastermind behind those she takes off any
mental load that i need to think about contemplate
anything of that nature but arisa is a fantastic helping hand and now i am
very happy to see arisa is also someone i consider a friend
because it has been lovely we've been chatting away
for a cheeky 45 minutes having a giggle having a
a gander um now you may notice on my screen that arisa is a png at the
moment but she mentioned she's streaming i wonder maybe
little reeflings in the future uh we might be doing a watch along of
someone's debut that's coming very soon and
there is uh i mean i don't know how much i'm allowed to see
am i allowed to say anything i'm so bad at keeping secrets specifically
relating to my own stuff not only do i get to leak veal or secrets at
all times i now get to leak arisa's debut secrets okay
um arisa has successfully acquired all the assets she needs for
debut which is fantastic so there's only one more thing
that we were waiting on which is the model and rigging
um and please do not think that this will be the only time you will see arisa
because i'm forcing you to watch her again and i say i dare say if our
friendship isn't ruined over this video game of moving out to that i will i
would very much love to collab with her again at some point so don't don't be
shy give arisa some love actually you know what i'll link here twitter
unfortunately uh arisa has been downgraded to a v-tweeter because she's
not streaming right now so unfortunately it is over for her it's over
um i promise i'm a streamer i love me
but don't be afraid to follow she's a hoot in a holler
um so we we we we we we we aren't french for one but
we are playing a game called moving out to which was developed by a australian
studio unbelievably and we are going to give it a
shot neither one of us have played it at all so you're
getting a live reaction of the shenanigans that are
about to ensue and have no idea so the whole the premise of
this stream is i've run out of funds to pay arisa for the
shenanigans which isn't quite the truth but
um arisa you know she gave me a little nudge she gave me a little wink and she
said you know what come do come move furniture with me
and then i'll i'll edit some stuff for free so okay okay you got me so
i'm ready to jump into it if you are yeah okay
right i need a file save oh we need a file save okay i am the frog
and the little creature the the miscellaneous creature that looks suspicious
in the shadows miscellaneous creature is the best way to describe youtube
design
oh voice acting well i don't have to read
oh i'm so cute look at the little crab oh i'm the lemon slice tag
yourself on the board i'm the lemon slice
i'm the i'm the busted banana i was gonna say refloons are you guys with
flimsy banana
oh
oh oh hey there i'm the boss here at smooth moves
but you can just call me boss you probably remember me from such block
busters is moving out one okay nice way to nice way to say that you've got
another game movers in paradise and my one man musical
entitled i'm the boss and what i'm the boss and moving out one in movers
in paradise but enough about me
that was all over eight years ago and a lot has changed around here
times have been tough none of the schmoovers uh
movers have come back to hack more since going to that perfect tax-free
tropical paradise i have no idea why no no the taxes
refund the high tables yeah that's you yeah
yes well i'm lucky you came back otherwise we'd be out of business
oh yeah about that
we lost our fart certification on that last move boss man
what how turns out you can he put fireworks
and actual fire in the same truck that was my bad sorry about that
well you're back to to training along with the new recruits
we need to get our fart levels back that's absolutely vile
okay this uh this might be a silly question
but what does fart actually stand for uh well that's easy it's fun at your
rearrangement and relocation technician
we're already printed the business cards before we realized the issue
should we embrace the fun oh my god this game's a 10 already i'm sorry i know
it's childish but i love this game literally
let's stop let's stop fluff around though let's get too far
okay tutorial time so i'm the froggy
and the rest of this one yeah i'm the little eyeball
yes and then i'm floggy right trigger to grab things
you link
all right so we go together pivot pivot it's the meme
it's the friends meme that everyone seems to know about
i have never seen friends but i do know pivot i know that i'm the same exact same
never watched it by no pivot pivot
i'm a natural farther i'm so good at passing the
what what does this mean i have i don't oh wait
there's a symbol of the downwards on this one
or am i going crazy okay and then what oh this is oh this is
oh and bits and bobs okay bits and bobs go here don't worry
reeflands we did it don't do you panic okay
we're so good at moving this honestly i'm enjoying this already
we're not even through the tutorial it's so cute yeah the art style is adorable
we were talking about if you want to
i want to throw them when holding
a okay wait oh oh you have a flashlight
i've made a horrible mistake i hope that wasn't expensive no
oh i can see your aim ball i can see your aim ball that's okay
owing
why would they do that why would they do this
just as our farters did however the sound volumes
then you turn the game off then you turn it down
you turn it up then you turn it down turn it up up up up up turn it up turn
it up turn it up turn it up oh sorry i didn't mean to start stealing off of
you where am i going to put this in the truck
oh no wonder everyone is moving out there's a
right in the zone oh no oh who's an estaban
you spin my hair around around around around around
i fear that every time i hear that song i hear the pitch perfect version
i've not seen that i should watch it really oh my god what
movie watch along where is it what both hold eggs and start to swing
oh no oh no right three two one go
oh you did it oh my gosh what's so good at this
what i didn't expect that
right hold on i'm holding x swing one
two two go go go go yeah oh my god
oh my god hold on oh you can slap things
nothing bad bad bad bad bad wait had to call me
oh no the target didn't come back up wait only i was allowed to do that
real i'm taking my basketball with yeah i'm taking this too this is mine
this is mine now there are many basketballs in the world but these ones
are ours yeah this is my son i'm naming him
brennan brennan the ball yeah i mean it's got brand in the ball
and i'm so wait five days without wait what was it you can high five or slap
objects with eggs
oh i'm sorry but it's smack the
loud it's smooth moves but only when used for moving purposes
you never know when you need to slap your co-worker thanks to the latest
in vocation may stick get that luggage in the truck and we're good to go
oh my i don't i'm not sure i need to slap a i'm not sure what slapping a
co-worker would do that would be beneficial to what shenanigans
we need to get oh there's a massive key
what i was rambling iris's ear off um if you are an ozzy game developer you
can actually get a grant for developing your game
um i don't know if it's like sydney region only or something
i've got an achievement for that reach fart level one
oh wait i got it too um we were talking about the grant
because it's considered culture video games are considered culture
the grant is worth 10 000 australian dollars or something like that
so anyway when you see me and irisa come up with a video game at a later date for
no particular reason at all uh you're gonna know what's up
you did it you're now far at level one oh yeah level one that's the top right
no not at all actually you have to earn higher levels on the job
you unlock more jobs the higher your level now let's get things back to normal
and by normal i mean the special brand of chaos smooth moves
ink is renowned for yeah okay we'll just do continue
because yeah i think we i think we nailed that
tutorial honestly for a game that i've never played before
nice and easy not confusion not confusion not computing
game congratulations on completing your training now it's time to get trucking
we've got jobs waiting hey slow down do you know how to drive a truck no i don't
know i definitely don't i don't have a license no i don't have one i don't
why what's the feature person not knowing how to drive
i don't know for the stereotype i can't believe it i've been on my l plates for
like five or six years now oh my god uh careful this truck isn't
made of rubber it's actually made of pixels which is way weirder
drive the truck using the left stick go and give it a shot oh
oh i'm doing it okay wait where am i supposed to go
how did that just spin out okay i guess that'll do try honking your horn with
y excellent the whole team can honk too
if you get lost while driving hold b to return to the headquarters
while you're cruising keep an eye out for missing movers and stale crates
oh don't worry if you hit anything the whole town has insurance now after
moving out one eating the trees i've got insurance for the trees
let's kick off with the nice easy job to get you settled back into pack
more it's a single level house let's move
oh my god okay i'm not gonna crash i promise i'm not gonna crash
right here we are what i do all right driving lessons over time to move out
oh my god this is so cute are we under a timer
oh there's no time well this all seems pretty normal
almost too normal yes this job definitely isn't to lull you
into a false sense of security but for all the weird stuff happens
what weird stuff okay and we're getting a bird's eye view of the
house it looks cute i'm here that's adorable
look at the froggy clock doing a little dig oh my god
okay i understand so we get movers get moving
okay right it's mine now i'm saving this for later
wait how did oh god what was that oh there's a banana on the bin
right so is it legit i mean fuck i'm taking the table the table's mine
okay it looks like we're stealing because the items like aren't
oh god oh my god you just ripped i think i broke that microwave
ripped out of the wall wait the box itself is something i've already
forgotten what the button was to like show off the stuff
i need to pick that up is it why oh no it's why okay
if you press y i'm taking the tv oh my god this game is amazing oh i broke the
window oh no okay i'm sorry morally what's the if i just
like
are you taking the toilet how do i can i just i think you can wait
maybe you can oh my god you can
no way let's let's take it let's take it no way
that is terrible okay i understand why they didn't change
now the grand thing we just do a little thieving what can i say
i'm taking the toaster is coming with me come on
i'm taking the fridge do you get bonus points for you like
even more maybe i'm gonna jump over the window and
then jump i'm leaping come on right i said the fridge is coming with us
i'm spamming the oh do we need to oh wait hold on maybe we just go out the
door like actually there was a door okay maybe the window wasn't the great idea
we don't need to struggle this badly
i squirkin though would you guys be honest riefling would you hire us
i would you don't i would hire us i'd hire me
absolutely i trust myself with all my worldly positions
oh so what you can throw stuff what's going on
well if you insist i'll go in the garden and grab this shit or don't mind if
i would hire 100 yeah but would you take us though for our
outstanding service you get reassured that um you've got people that are going
to deal with your move out and you come back and everything's smashed up
all your private properties being ransacked oh my god
this is fine this isn't the house anymore oh wait no we've been out but the new owners
have to deal with this literally actually yeah we've just saved you like so much
time you don't need to hire like even if you're renting the rental people
can't come for you for it yeah so really landlords are evil anyway we're
doing a favor real if i had if i had a dollar for every
time a landlord did something evil i'd have like three dollars which isn't a
lot but that's every single landlord i've ever had so i don't i don't know
i don't know um i had a landlord uh keep 200
great british pounds because there was a black mark on
uh a door that could be removed so that was really fun bro
and i couldn't argue it because i'd already left the country
so i was literally couldn't do a thing about it
oh to me to you oh no you've not oh you've never seen it
um so there's this british tv show called um chuckle vision
and then two of the guys like they do like bumping they basically move furniture
and they always go to me to you to you to me wait don't give up we're not giving
up why would we give up we would never give up
we're so good at oh we're so good at moving oh no hold on i think i'm gonna
have to like stack some of this wait can i
we've overstocked it how do we put it i'm trying to like make room for the bed
i'm trying oh god this is inventory management
oh we did it we did it hello police
yippie easy peasy let me try arissa the
reeflings are asking what are you they've called you at most
yeah i am a uh i guess i'm an amalgamation uh i am a monster girl
uh and i am a combination of a rat folk
a beholder a mimic and a bone devil because i'm a dnd dad
oh you're dnd there that's so cute i play twice a week every week oh my god
that's so precious um apparently we've got
some a policeman just called on us hello police a
coefficient a dnd rat also just ransacked my house and
destroyed all my property they keep singing some song about not
having mercy on a cult first like strangers please help wee wee wee
thank you um what does juicing citrus have to do with moving out
we crushed it yeah yeah lucky your moves are better than your jokes
the next job is i like you getting solid honestly
a combination would be called a kind of rude for being an amalgamation
i'm so good at comedy the next job is waiting
right i i got shorts to pay for sorry but i got shorts to pay for we gotta
we gotta go to the next place billy's bungalow
past time protein let that sink in zap it was burning
wait there's hidden stuff we can cook in the game in the middle of the game
ah let that sink in as in from outside to the inside you'll need these to
progress up the fart levels you know the game design
reminds me of overcooked is this the same people
they look it looks like overcooked i think i'm going crazy you'll need
these to progress up your fart levels and for your annual performance review
annual stereo
uh someone says rat folk beholder mimic bone devil girl for jen
oh my god this is so cute
oh my oh right okay oh my god sorry the map is just so adorable
i love this okay
they should not have given me a beat beat button it's over for everyone in this
neighborhood you did great on the first move but don't
get too comfy the next job i'm clear i'm gonna sit down on the couch and get
very comfy literally the next job called and
called and need to be out of there quick as they just saw spider in the house
uh for an australian game real and true i saw my first huntsman spider and i
was speechless okay i was speechless i was like get out of here you bastard
honestly i was having it
when you like spend your whole life here we have so many like big spiders that
when you just see a little spider in your room like that's just my pal now
like that's a roommate it's fine he pays rent by eating the flies
yeah that's literally no it was horrifying so in skulls uh
cockroaches aren't a thing so i got to see my first cockroach as well
that really cockroaches are awful uh my cat hunted one and gave it to me as a
gift and then she ate it in front of me so that was lovely
lovely leveling up means going up a level right okay watch those stairs
ooh stairs i love stairs wait why am i american i don't know i love the feeling
the burn deep in my eyes okay we're getting a bird's eye view of the map
we're scanning we're scanning there's a few bits and bobs
i don't know how you're supposed to know what the secret object is
ready bust a move oh yeah break it down break it down break it down
break it down break it down yeah yeah yeah yeah
spank that door open boom oh it hit me oh it just hit me back i'm beating the
store how dare you wait how did i do this
this is the worst wait what if we hit the microwave is that how we do it
oh it must be it must be smack interaction but how do you know what the mission
objective is i'm just smacking everything well
my hands are there's cars bumping out of here
what a unique game honestly i'm here for i'm here for it right i'm bringing the
grill oh wait no no i can't i was going to say
do i need to like open the grill in order to put it away
aren't huntsman spiders good to have around they might be
that's something a huntsman spider would say i'm being i'm gonna be honest
that was awfully suspicious of you that was awfully suspicious behavior but
they are a good to have around because they deal with the bugs
but um they are rather terrifying because
they don't actually sit like a regular
spider they sit like almost like a love heart if that makes sense because their
wee leggies are all crossed in on each other
so it makes some extra menacing especially considering like the biggest
spider in scotland is probably like five centimeters or
something like i have never seen anything of that nature until
summer first huntsman and he was such a cheeky shite because
um i think i must have been in my rental for about a week before he decided to
show up and i'm like where did you come from because all the windows and doors
like have those screens for bugs yeah um because in
scotland we actually don't have them so i was like oh my god this technology is
so advanced my my scottish brain cannot
comprehend how advanced this technology is
when i was a kid i'd always seen like american movies when the kids just like
sneak out of the house and they just like leave through the window and then when
is your fly screen yes we don't we don't have that in the
uk we just like suffer if you want if you want to open your window like on a
hot blistery day uh yeah you just accept that you're getting
bugs you're getting yeah they're called blue balls and
scotland and icky oh my god this is so cannot
you're coming with me i'm so determined to find one of like the
hidden things if i press start is it gonna tell us
no oh your game continues even when i pause on that end oh yeah okay that's
actually kind of good because it could not tell you how many games they code
where it's like oh what's that one person paused i will now
stop all of you from being able to progress uh i'm trying so badly to stack
these because i know when it comes to the later stuff i'm gonna mess up so
badly we've got it we've got to get our our puzzle
brains on and no i i cannot for the life of me i never played tetris before
i have played tetris but i've never been good at tetris
i used to watch speedruns of it on youtube randomly like i'd never played
it myself but i find it fascinating watching people like break world
records or that in video games and i used to watch
how does someone's brain like process shapes that
okay this is not we didn't need to move this uh we can bring it
stolen this yeah don't tell them don't tell them don't tell them
we'll we'll steal the okay wait so what we do we do the pivot moment yep
surely this will go fine and not be a problem at all
hold on let me get out of the way okay okay pivot
it's actually happening it's actually happening hold on right there we go
okay okay yeah that was a somehow a lot easier than i first
imagined shortcut
right through their house right through their lovely windows
see it wouldn't it wouldn't have happened if they had a fly screen so
not that i'm victim blaming or anything but if they had a fly screen i wouldn't
be able to do that why can i not yeah what is
wait does this not fit through the door i don't do we have to take this through
a window through the window through the wall to the wall
oh no mommy did it yeah okay we're doing it we're doing it that car is a bump
in that one over there we just don't steal it
let's see what happens a little grand theft oh oh how do i get stuck in the
door not only are we stealing this beach chair but we
think we it can't be proved okay we're just doing what we need to
oh there's a there's a there's a barrier
stinky that's that i'm throwing a flamingo at it
that's where you get you're so stinky oh my god why is that pivot so
okay that was actually useless
hi arisa hope your debut goes well are you
asked us like strong or will you just be streaming games
we've got a question for you arisa refilm wants to know
um are you going to be an ace of artists like me
or are you just going to be streaming games what's your focus on content when
you debut uh i am primarily going to be doing
games and just chatting but i do really enjoy asmr so i do want to try it at
some point but i don't think it's going to be a
focus for me oh it is very fun oh it is some more
yeah tell me tell me to what's it oh what they call is it
is it gonna fortune when you put it on a whirligig and throw like the alcohol
around or something that like a good good bag isn't
i'm not called a good bag of alcohol yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey i'm here for it i'll make you do the most stereotypical asmr possible
the absolutely correct index is this the last item
oh maybe oh wait there's one more don't give up
do we keep missing like right at the perfect
a maybe oh we did it yeah it's fashion darling
fainter stale crate what oh that was smooth
shotgun on the truck i don't think we're licensed to carry viral
oh my god you do what we get you do i like me
yeah they call me comedy
i don't know what you meant but i was like is that a pun what does that mean
no i it's a stupid bit that i do i just keep saying it
they call me comedy that doesn't explain walks walks away
um each new crate will have a section selection of the latest looks
for each of our employees from i have to conjure to hot dogs the catwalks of
parry ain't got nothing unpack more okay get over there and glow up
we get outfits i'm like so great oh wait that's you sorry
sorry i'm like so crates right now socrates like the greek philosopher
no i can't work at a toga toga toga toga toga
hey they call her comedy because i need to finish this exactly
oh my god what is that like a it's a hot dog uh taco and onigiri
yeah finally some new outfits this lettuce is getting soggy
i'm not lettuce i'm a little thing in my boba which i've already forgot
oh we get to go to beach little beach house
coming through don't get away it's your fault if you get hit and run
okay we did it we're at the beach it's the cat shack hope you brought your
bathing suits because the next job is at the beach
oh sorry i just found i don't know what that line was
the clients were sick of always getting actual sand in their sandwiches
so they're headed for the countryside oh yeah yeah pools
wow since inventing the jump throw oh i can read it
sniffing strone's microphone no there'll be no sniffing microphones after emi's
recent ban i still can't believe that i don't know if you
now because you're a rat arissa uh you're not allowed to sniff on the
microphone because youtube literally gave her a strike
because she brought her rat on the mic i'm still speechless like
we tried to escalate it with the the youtube help and all that
and in the monetization tab and all that and they were like we got to the
highest chain of command that we could get and they were like
we understand it's a rat we're not removing it and it was like what
what are you on about you literally admitted that it's a rat
on the microphone is the reason she's got us like oh
anyway i shouldn't get into it because i'll start my blood pressure is rising
just thinking about it okay now remember pigs can't fly but
boxes can okay throw things to save time
are you sure pigs can't fly i met one that had
a pilot's license the other day that no no i didn't
okay we're taking an investigation of this area there's a down oh there's a
pool downstairs these people are rich rich
they're by the beach and have their own water
it's time to pass the move give me the crab
hehehe did we need to put them in the ocean
oh maybe oh what did i just break uh i don't know how do i get up there oh
what do you want oh it's like a little game boy game
ah
did you kill him i think i killed him oh no there's koi in the pond
you fed up to the fishes oh no oh wait i'm to grab this item oh no he's back
hello oh he's okay what does he want does he want anything in the picture
hi buddy yeah can we like give him a little give him a little treat
i'm gonna pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat pat
hello no oh does he just want oh he's he's just
coded to get in the way i think oh oh you can jump on parasols apparently
we're learning
smack that parasol open oh maybe i feel like we are supposed to put them
in the sea somehow yeah i feel like there's definitely something we have to
do with him go over there okay that didn't work
go over there into the sea no what the heck right i'll just let him do his thing
down there we should maybe oh it's a slight door
oh there oh my god there there look they could oh okay okay this has to be it
this has to be it there's no way that we are reuniting him with his family
no what no come on please oh i'm so sorry how did he close the door on the
smack up against the door and it didn't work
oh i don't i'm sure it refills you're gonna know it just keep the crab just
keep him as a pet we'll just take him with us in the
the thing all the time can we go through like the
backyard me can you breathe no they're not
damn the game's no having a hmm i feel like
i oh god that door keeps stop closing jeez
oh it does look like we're supposed to give him back over
and i bet you when we finish it that it would be like the secret side mission
reunite the family and we're like bro we literally tried we tried hard
i'm putting this i don't know maybe we're to cook him i know that sounds really
morbid but like if we're not supposed to reunite the crab then
you know in front of his family
i mean this is what happens when you get lost you get kicked alive
mommy can we keep it i don't think we can keep it i don't know how to look
after a pet crab
i've been when i go get food for gimli and vego
they sell like painted kermit no can't not kermit what they called
those crabs with no not crab ah what they called
their shells are like painted oh no it is a hermit crab shells i used to have
them oh you had them yeah when i was a kid i had
fed hermit crabs oh my god how was it like keeping them
were they easy or i think i think they were easy but
mostly because i was a small child and i didn't really have to do much of the
work so i honestly don't know is that i can't remember looking after them
they lived a happy life that's the main thing
um yeah whenever i go to like the paint stores they've painted the backs of the
of them and i'm like i don't know i don't know if it's unhealthy but then again
they don't eat like their shell or anything like that so it's not
what i imagine anything oh how did i drop them
um but yeah they're very very unique bits i had a hamster
um but that was a terrible idea because um i also had cats in my childhood in the
hamsters the cats used to like watch them all the
time like as entertainment but luckily nothing happened but
something easily could have happened to me
the fish no the fishbowl isn't an item
oh the fishbowl is an item oh why does it say break it i'm supposed to break this
maybe i wasn't supposed to break it oh no right there is it's back okay it's fine
don't give up we're not giving up we're not we're not trying to speedrun this
wait you threw net across oh my god that's yeah boing oh main breaks wait
why did you die going into the water oh no i thought routes were good swimmers
what the heck i thought so too okay i'm going to gently put this down
and then i'm going to open the door so this doesn't break
come on oh wait we should we should toss the the couch across
can we do that i think so oh wait the door's there sorry i'm a dumb
i see it okay right let's light if the door excuse me door can you close thank
you that way that way no it's okay okay there we go right and then i hold x and
then one two three three
right
perfect shot hollard one so good wait did i need to go open up the thing
hold wait i'll open up the parasol again because we'll do it with the
next thing yeah oh my god you that was so cool i love this game it's so cute it's
so cute
okay come on come on let's go let's go let's go one two oh sorry i was going
out these doors again just didn't just to get in the way
it's gonna break the door you can't prove it it wasn't me okay no it doesn't do
anything one one two and three
shit that came out it worked yeah oh my god that's so good that is so good i love
that mechanic that's amazing right i think we might have to manually
direct or did we just throw it again because the thing didn't shut
oh my god we're actually the best movers in all the land if you guys want to
hire movers and you're in australia let us come
because hold on hold on hold on hold on i'm
right don't don't that that that wasn't don't put that in the advertisement
reel for the big okay that was a mistake right yeah that was an
advertisement of what we don't do exactly that was a one two three
oh my god that is so good i love that mechanic so much it's so fun what is this
a sunbench can i i think i can just drag this all the way
i'm not quite this is so good
why is my oh she evil you know what sometimes i'm just misunderstood i'm
not evil i promise okay hold on let me open that
door for you so that doesn't smash because that thing
smashes so evenly
wait we run out of time oh my god sorry i think we're about to
i didn't know the game had its actual timer yeah i thought it was like
i thought this was a suggestion yeah like oh we we suggest the time to you but
we don't actually right i think oh i think we throw it
across the water and then we pull it up the stairs right
okay three oh wait hold on that's me doing that wrong
can i throw it i know you could lose in this game are you serious
bro i was like having fun just like yapping away yeah
wait so we can continue or do we have to like go back to the job
uh let's find out maybe we can progress to the next please
i don't know probably not know that i think about it
okay okay i think i want us to do it again
i can't believe it right don't put that in the advertisement reel of the moving
business either okay right i'll skip through this
right we're gonna speedrun it this time okay i'm gonna grab all the wee things
and then we'll toss them all over with the umbrella okay
right on your marks movers get moving i'm off i'm off
here we go what should we call you
a reflin ask hey aresa if reflin's call me mommy what
what should we call you as in what what what reflin should call
a rhythm oh i don't know are you got like a name
or a nickname or something about a chord
i'm not sure i haven't thought about that before you guys are just gonna have to
give her a nickname though yeah yeah i could work with
something
if i had to give you a nickname i really like that you're a mimic chest
i make sense now like because you the different design element
but i really like mimic mimic is a cute little name
we mimic mr crab not now we are trying to speedrun you
don't understand we are mlg gamers oh my gosh right
let's get going i'm smashing everything up in this place i'm
smashing everything right i'm grabbing the wee items first
i'm not losing rubber t destruction i'm not losing again sorry but we are
two mlg we are real gamers out in these actually i never asked what kind of
games do you play uh genuinely pretty uh
don't look don't look don't look i was a miss input miss input
uh i genuinely play pretty much anything uh
i'm pretty much the only games i don't play a like
uh like your typical like uh overwatch valorant like first-person
shooting yeah but other than that like i i play a lot of
dating sims i play a lot of the regular sims i play uh i've been playing
minecraft since 1.3.1
i also just like uh like collab games as well like i'm a big monster
fan i like like gang beasts and all that kind of stuff
jackbox i have played so much jackbox it's unbelievable
aww no these games are really good
yeah what would you what would you say your top three games are though
that's the real that's the real the thing is minecraft in it
um i don't know actually i think a couple years ago i would have said it was
but like i think definitely my number one game
is uh i the somnium files it's a yeah it's kind of a niche one
it's a uh murder mystery uh investigation game where you like solve the
murders by like going into people's dreams okay
yeah it's it's really fun i love it it's uh it's really good
uh i have beaten it twice is it difficult
um can i uh oh whoa close enough we did it
literally i will pull this up the stairs right now
i think the game wasn't uh i haven't done that i don't know how i did
i have some superhuman strength right now going on
um
is the wrist like stated for date everything i am
oh my god it's it's like that game was made specifically for me
what was that a vote am i allowed to ask yeah it's uh it's a dating sim where the
premise is that like you get fired from your job and then someone leaves like a
set of glasses at your door uh and they just kind of
turn all of your furniture and like everything into your house into like a
living like a person uh so you can literally date
like everything in your house and they have like a stacked voice acting cast
too like everyone's in it oh okay
it's the kind of insane nonsense that i live for
like this goofy unserious games that don't
oh my god that's so cute i had no i've never heard of that i don't really play
visual novel like dating sim games but i should give them a shot because they
are they're a massive genre massive genre oh god i'm messing this up so badly
how am i swaying so much oh no i never open out oh well that's fine
so let it we're good getting close i'm trying are you squiddin me right now
i think kareesa could be a great collab with me
she loves rats after all uh reflynn says i think iris there could be a great
club but i mean because she loves wait we did it
yeah let's see right okay we need uh throwing is so much fun but not in
video games i could throw all day
and i what does it what does it have for this stuff even mean i don't know
long as we're having fun with the dialogues that's the main thing
oh we were so close to the pro time arcade cartridge collected find hidden
arcade eh i have a surprise movers we've found a
way for you to do even more work real and true certain levels have a hidden
arcade cart that will unlock bonus jobs happy cart hunting
okay rinse off the sand don't use the sliding door it
items off the umbrella you wouldn't know until like you actually had
done it yeah i guess maybe it's a i guess maybe this is one of those games
where like you're supposed to play it like one run through
involving it and then doing like a full collection yeah that's the replay ability
for yeah definitely look we found an arcade car it must be for the new arcade
down the road oh there's a new arcade down the road
yeah the building that says okay
okay oh that's so cute right let's do that
oh that arcade that's the one you're on about so now once we've finished work
we can relax with a little more work oh no yes i want all the carts
there's more carts hidden out there movers so keep your eyes peeled
we have to peel our eyes like an orange
yes keep your eyes open
okay no we'll do the arcade first because i don't know what
yeah
we've unlocked twists of fury i can't select anything else so move or lose it
says the boss
buster move with what the couch
huh oh it's a maze oh no i understand i understand oh no mazes are my biggest
nemesis i was joking about the pivot mean i'm not joking this is like pivot
central pivot wait
i need to stick it down here and then like pivot it back out
oh my gosh this is i like sorry is is is annoying this is going to be this is
actually hilarious yeah that's really funny because you have to take the
the pin oh full spin yeah okay we've done the first section okay
we've unlocked the neck wait oh god don't touch the red oh my god
right okay okay safety safe safe safe safe safe next
checkpoint uh okay you ready i can go backwards
okay
hold on hold on don't drop me jump jump jump jump jump don't drop me okay okay
oh no okay that one that one's out that one's so well right
three two one go go go go go go go go go okay we're safe we're safe we're safe
we're safe oh my god this is funny
what's the good at moving okay what is this uh we're guessing like single fail
it right okay three two one one go
oh okay they're bouncy that's okay i thought it was like knock out if you
touch them they're just bouncy we're safe we're safe refunds we're doing it
we're doing it if this does if this doesn't want to make you
higher as afterwards i don't know what yeah okay no no no no no no no no no no
and then take a break and then no no no no no no no oh wait no i fucked up
okay okay okay we're fine we're fine let me let's let's go
i'll be down the way yeah like that okay read read just read just
three two no no no no no no oh
okay i keep messing up right i'll i'll do i'll be down the way i keep okay okay three
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
we did it oh my god that was so good for a bonus level sorry that was that was good
i like this we're the so we're the hell are these people move into literally the best
what what oh sorry okay let's do tokyo drift that's a little i'm just going to start on them
doing a little smooth moves headquarters now okay let's see nice level oh what shenanigans
where that truck going when i need well when i need furniture moved to my evil villain layer
i'll call you to exact yes yeah that's exactly what we're here for the next client is the best door
salesman in fact war get this move right and it will open up a lot of well doors incredible you
could say smooth move success hinges on it
okay this job is about moving in just do what you normally do but backwards
backwards speak do we sure as long as you move everything from the truck to the right spot
move in put everything back into the right places and by put we mean throw oh i mean i'm not
gonna complain okay we're having a bird's eye view that bird's eye view we're looking we're
observing we're using our eyeballs in the case of irissa her many eyeballs
okay i i just go for it i'm just going for it i don't know i don't know anything i'm just here for
a good time uh all right okay i'll i just oh myself okay so it's highly agreed for the item
that you can move in that position okay yeah all right all right all right all right okay forget
that door all right all right all right all right all right all right all right oh my mom loves this
Let's go and know it by default.
Ow, I keep getting myself for that rake as well.
Ow, I just thought, let's see.
OK, I can't pull it that way then.
I've got you, I've got you.
Me, me, pivot.
How have I made it go sideways?
Wait, it can't come in this way?
Can we, like, slap it?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, slap it, all right.
When and don't give it a good slap, OK?
Yeah.
Right, what is it?
Oh, it's a grandfather clock.
My grandfather?
Aw, I like how the stepping stones in the garden is like a...
Oh, no, I thought it was a keyhole, but I guess not, maybe.
Oh, no, the clock is counting down because we're moving in.
Oh, the game's so mean.
Why would it do that to it?
How do I open this door?
The paint.
Wait, do we have to unlock sections of the house?
Oh, maybe.
Oh, my God, it may be you have to finish it room by room
and then it'll open up because...
Wait, I'm stuck.
No, there's a freaking window.
I need, you need to go all the way around again
in order to get access.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, my goodness, Carly.
This game is getting a bit harder, I know where.
I can't believe it, I can't believe it.
I see this rake, I can't even pick it up.
I can't even pick it up.
I'm making it ten times worse.
Is there a broken window here?
Oh, that's what it is.
It's a window you can break into at the back.
Oh, wow.
Oh, God, they did not make it easy.
Sorry about the beat this hard out of nowhere.
I'm not smart enough for this kind of stuff.
Give me, give me, give me.
Some doors can only be opened from the side.
Oh, there may be sideway doors as well.
Oh, that honestly makes a lot more sense.
Now that you've said that out loud.
And this is why I allow stream sniping personally.
That's fair.
Oh, no, our backseat game in, I think,
is the terminology as well.
Why, what are your rules?
Are you a backseat gamer or are you a lover or are you like,
or let me try and figure it out first.
OK, I don't know how I want air.
OK, the computer's in place.
I'm doing it.
I'm getting paid.
I think I'm stuck at this room.
The window?
Yeah, it won't let me move this box out of here.
To get out.
Yeah, like, I can't, like, I can't take it through the window.
But I also, wait, hold on, let me come in.
Yeah, no, I don't think it's full of this room.
Let me, if I can get this chair over here, I'm coming.
I'll help, I'll help.
Help is on the way, dear.
Help is on the way.
We got this, we got this.
Can I come out in this part?
Right.
Right, we're going to take it through the room.
I said we're going to take it through the room.
And then we need to take it weird down here.
There we go, there we go.
And then, OK, so it is like you can go out,
but you can't go in.
Oh, my God, this is getting redunctious.
I actually love how Arissa's VTuber model looks.
It's very cute.
Wait until you see the actual model.
I can't wait for it.
I've asked her to, again, with the ring.
I've asked her to leak it.
Wait, where does this go?
Up top left.
Oh, my God.
OK, it's top left.
Let's go around the ring.
Yes, round the dang thing.
Around the other way.
Getting close.
No, I'm not even started.
Bro, I can't.
Right, there we go.
And then let us in this way.
Yes, OK, we're in, we're in.
We're in.
This is what we wanted.
This is what we've been waiting for.
Yeah.
OK, that was moved out the way.
Where does this ring go?
Ow.
You see this ring?
I keep forgetting its existence and it's ruining my life.
Not to be dramatic, but it's literally ruining my life.
Not to be dramatic, but it's evil and should die.
Yes, it will perish.
No, not even jump in this window?
Maybe we can't up the two people because I
couldn't draw another window before.
Oh, maybe.
OK, let's run.
Why does my character?
My character like sweeps when I do it that way.
No, go in.
That does seem that does seem right, though.
Oh, we did it.
Oh, thank you.
Ow, I forgot about the rape.
The absolute deviant of society.
Who knew it would be our biggest enemy in this game?
Oh, right, a shell.
How have we only got two minutes?
Sorry, this level is so hard for no reason.
They're like, oh, here's the easiest game in the world,
by the way.
OK, now we're going to make it insanely difficult out
of nowhere, like, oh, thank you, I guess.
We're so glad you thought that our game was cute and fun
and easy.
How would you feel about it not being that right now?
I don't know if we make it stressful out of nowhere.
Oh my god, how?
Right, OK, these boxes we can run away with each
because they're singular.
One in here.
Where does this one go?
Oh, this way.
OK, bink, bink, bad boom, bad boom, pow.
No.
And then we've got a desk.
OK, this is going to be a bit.
This is massive.
Bruh, who needs a desk this size?
Wait, Danny, wait.
If I go inside, can I open the doors for you?
Oh, baby.
Oh, right, there he is.
OK, it's coming together.
It's coming together.
We're doing it.
I'm so smart.
This is why we get paid the big bucks for this job, OK?
I know you're.
I know, Reeflings, you can't comprehend
that we're worth so much money, but I assure you that we
take away the stress of what you.
All $40 billion we get paid every year
is 100% worth your taxpayer dollars.
Exactly.
And our prices don't include the personal tax
that you have to pay us.
I think we're going to have to.
Can we throw this thing?
Yeah, exactly.
We're going to throw it.
Unless OK, OK, OK, hold on.
Let me go.
It's giving me the the vibrati buzz thing.
So yeah, one, two, three.
Oh my god, that was perfect.
OK, I just lawless.
I literally just need to wiggle it over here and we're done.
OK, we're missing one.
Are we?
I'm getting an arrow this way.
Ah, the rig.
Oh, there you go, there you go.
Oh, I'll go.
I'll go.
No, I won't, no, I won't.
Hold on, hold on.
On the end, I'll open the door, open the door.
My lady.
See, this is this is my lady.
I forget to move.
And they see chivalry is there.
Exactly.
I throw it.
That was there we go.
Please.
I'm going to buy.
OK, moving in, complete a moving in level.
No sweat.
That was terrible.
The doors, I love that.
I love the bed.
We just need we just need to break it,
break on through to the other side.
Exactly.
This house is adorable.
OK, that's enough puns for this job.
Oh, adorable.
Oh, get it.
Hardy, hardy, hard, adorable, hardy, hardy, hardy, hardy.
And this is chivalry.
OK, that was curious.
The key the secret is key when you
got a go on the move.
I'm allergic to sliding doors.
Oh, I'm guess you can get the table in that window, I guess.
Oh, yeah.
Shocking the movie.
We go across the bridge.
Hello.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
I think I prefer the removal jobs.
Unless they make the moving jobs easier.
This is all going smoothly.
A whole day without a single conspiracy
or supermaterial incident.
The next job should be a piece of cake.
Are we about to get haunted?
I love being haunted.
Shame we don't get lunch breaks.
Or do we not?
Or dinner breaks.
Do they not feed us?
But we do break a lot of things.
So it pallets us out.
It makes the difference.
Chalet la fire.
I'm not even going to pretend I know what that means.
No, no French for me.
Not today, anyway.
This place just sold for a fortune.
Pack more house prices have gone through the roof.
Since we got voted town least likely to have a sloth
infestation, everyone wants to live here.
It's not even possible.
But we had a sloth infestation last year.
Yeah, so it's not very likely now.
OK, that's true.
True.
Sloth is so cute.
Remember that thing?
What is that Australian meme about the co-op?
Is it drop bears?
Yeah, drop bears.
Yeah, I got fricken.
I got fooled into thinking it was a real thing.
It is real.
100%.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Someone is actually in Australia right now.
Yeah, yeah, drop bears.
And so are haggis.
Haggis reveal animals that you can only hunt during June
and August because that's when breeding season is.
And there are numbers get out of control if you don't.
Exactly.
I will see.
Unironically, though, last night at D&D.
My game has.
There we go.
OK.
Unironically, last night at D&D, there
was a koala outside my friend's house at night.
And they make such a horrible noise that we were like, OK,
so the drop bears are real.
And they're right there.
Honestly, they're terrifying.
That picture you see of the drop bear, the meme,
so for those of you who are uninitiated, why?
I'm making it worse.
I'm standing on the furniture.
How is this not?
Right, there we go.
For those of you uninitiated, OK,
there's a picture of a wet koala that looks absolutely
horrifying.
It is like hanging off of a tree.
It is the most terrifying thing.
No, do not grab the pot.
And it is like the most mortifying thing.
So Aussies call it a drop bear.
And my dumb ass thought it was real.
I thought it was a real animal because there's tons of animals
I've never seen before.
Like, it's like a marsupial type.
It's not kangaroo.
It was a.
Does it begin with a Q?
A quokka?
Possibly.
There's, like, tons of stuff I've never seen before.
Yeah.
So, like, I didn't question it.
I put my trust in the Aussies.
I put my faith in the Aussies.
And how do I get repaid by having that trust abused?
And by abused, I mean, I just believe a little tee hee thing.
It's kind of like when don't ever let a Scottish person tell you
that haggis are animals, by the way.
Haggis is literally just sheep, lungs, and intestines
all mashed up with a few spices, OK?
It's not an actual animal.
But if next time you hear me mention haggis,
I will say it's an animal just for the heck of it.
So, yes, I may have been a fool to the Aussies' drop bear.
Clean.
The funniest thing about the drop bear thing is that, you know,
we love to mess with people and tell people that the drop bear is real.
But, like, we kind of, that's kind of, we don't have to
because we have animals that are just that weird and real life.
Yes.
Like, we don't have to lie about having weird animals.
Exactly.
Like, if you've ever seen a kangaroo, they are horrifying,
but not for the reason you think.
They're horrifying because they balance on their tails.
It looks like their little tail is going to snap off
because they put all the weight on it.
And it is just the most bizarre thing.
If you've ever seen a kangaroo, like, fight as well,
those things are mortifying.
There's, like, a viral video of this kangaroo having a dog in its arms or whatever.
And then the owner comes up to the kangaroo, like, fill-grown kangaroo,
and wallops them in the face.
And the kangaroo is, like, stunned that he's been walloped in the face.
It's just the most bizarre thing ever.
But, like, they have, like, claws on their feet as well
to, like, open up the guts of their enemies.
Like, it's just craziness, honestly.
Absolutely craziness.
They're scary little creatures.
They are mortifying little things.
And they do just, like, hang out, like, in the suburbs and stuff, too.
They're not just out in the wild.
Sometimes you always be at the shop, so there's just one hanging out.
Yeah, like, I'm very lucky that I haven't had to deal with encountering the wildlife.
The most wildlife experience I have is, literally, I feed magpies,
so I've never been swept by a magpie.
They're all super happy when they call on me and that.
It's really sweet, I love them.
But I have been swept by those fake magpies,
like, the smaller black and white ones swept me,
and I was like, eh, excuse you.
But there's still quite a lot of funny videos online
of, like, kids getting swept by a magpie.
There's one kid, he's, like, screaming down a hill,
because he's terrified, and I feel so bad for laughing,
but it is a wee bit funny.
It's a wee bit funny.
A couple weeks ago, some of my friends and I played pommel party,
none of them are Australian, they're American and Canadian.
So I, there was, in the game, one of the cosmetics you can get
is, like, a bike helmet with spikes on it,
and I was like, oh my god, my culture.
And they were like, what are you talking about?
And I said, oh, you know, the magpie helmets.
And they were like, what are you saying?
And I was like, you know, the helmets that you put on
so you don't get attacked by magpies during swooping season,
and they were like, there's a season?
Yep, there is, absolutely.
No, I got to learn about that too often.
Out of the way!
We could probably throw this across.
Could we?
Yeah, okay.
Oh, we should do the couch first, because it's in the way.
Okay.
No, like, the people put, like, just, oh no, okay,
one, two, three.
Ah, fuck it, just send it, send it, send it.
Yeah, close enough, close enough.
Send everything, everything.
Ring the cards.
Hold on.
One and two, just on two.
Two, two.
There we go.
Okay, we're doing it, we're doing it, we're doing it, we're doing it.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
We're yapping too much, we're out of time.
We're getting, our pee's going to get docked.
Is it docked?
Yeah, six at one and two.
Right, okay, one more time.
Hold on, give us another chance.
One and two.
Okay, that throw thing is actually a really fair mechanic.
Sorry, that is really well done, they've done that.
I guess we just walk out the door with this one.
Just the, we did it.
Right, okay, I'm satisfied we didn't mess this one up.
Yeah.
And then the fridge, the refrigerator.
But yes, in order for magpies to stop swooping,
people put like plastic spikes on their helmet
or you can put zip locks on your helmet.
Yeah, the zip ties are my favorite strategy.
Yeah, or you can get, find a missing employee.
Huh?
The rat on the boat.
I don't know, I don't think I'm missing employee.
It's fishing.
Smashed it, I love doing our part to keep property prices down.
We should start a window company too.
Actually we should.
And maybe a broom company.
I can see it happening.
Just had a 14-hour work day.
Oh no, I hope you're okay.
Break all the windows, keep your...
The one time we didn't.
Literally.
Character create.
Kaku to you too buddy.
I don't know what we did.
The missing employee, can you help me find the rest of them?
I invested all their wages and pictures of monkeys burning money.
What?
Is that a reference to something?
They are going to be so half...
Wait, is that a reference to the NFTs?
I don't know.
Monkeys burning money?
That's the only thing my brain can come up with for a reference.
Yeah.
Refrigerator.
Yeah I thought it was the NFTs too.
Hello, my name is...
Ah, the little testers!
Is something burning?
Oh, it's just me.
I'm looking.
Hats, toast, waffle, pizza and a poster?
Is that right?
I can't wait to unlock the air fryer character.
Okay, hydration check.
I need some water.
Yeah, I'll hydrate too.
This is a very good game.
I'm very happy with that.
It was so fun.
Money will spend.
It's on Xbox Game Pass right now.
If anyone's curious, play with us.
Hello, we're here to do the mission.
Yeah.
They say never work with animals.
Excuse me, this coefficient rat is very polite.
We've been nothing but nice.
We've been as respectful as possible.
What are you on about?
Unless the animals...
We're so good at our job.
Yeah, unless the animals pay 27.3% more?
Hang on, half of the smooth movers are animals.
How dare you?
Are we getting hate crimes?
Do we need support for HR?
Hold on a minute, where's HR when you need them?
They say pigs can't fly.
What?
What is this?
Who's come?
Chickens can't fly either.
Chickens can't fly as they don't have the required ratio of wing area to body mass.
This...
Oh, sorry.
Your turn.
This lack of appropriate wing loading means they are not able to generate required lift
to launch themselves more than a very short distance.
They can only launch a short distance?
We can change that.
Let's throw the chickens.
We are prevailing the animals, but we're the sheep dog this time.
Right, this is going to be serious.
Right, sheep.
Where does sheep go?
She'd go up here.
Sheep, in here.
Wait, what?
I need to...
Ow!
There's a shovel there, don't step on it.
Wait, how do I put them in?
Hold on, you guys are going to...
Do we both have to do it?
Like, throw them in?
Yeah.
Try...
No, I think because he's only one, it's not...
Yeah.
Oh!
I can...
Okay, sorry.
That was kind of...
Sorry, my bad, Chief.
It's solidified.
Oh, he's golden.
Yeah.
Come here, chicken!
Come here!
Oh, did you know that a chicken in Australia is called a chook?
Yeah!
What a funny word.
So, the live ones do.
We just call them all chooks.
Aw, I didn't know the live ones were called.
I thought it was only the food when they...
Yeah.
Where they're...
Why can I not grab a chicken?
Chief, stay in here!
This is...
That's just my life as a bird, I don't know.
It's just like that.
Oh, you want birds?
Yeah, I have a little cognac called Bandit.
Oh, my God, Bandit!
Such a perfect name!
We Bandit!
That's precious.
He's a little menace, but I love him very much.
Aw!
Does he make loads of noises in the background?
He does.
He's actually learned how to do a kissy noise recently, which is adorable.
Oh, my God!
I love it!
You'll need to send me a wee picture.
Where does this turtle go?
Does this turtle go anywhere?
Or is this a distraction?
I think the turtle's a distraction because...
Yeah.
Okay, do we want to try grab this cow?
Yeah, actually.
Let's deal with the cows because they're awkward.
Is this a...
Right, how...
Wait.
Okay, maybe...
Oh, right, okay.
We're doing it, we're doing it.
There we go.
And then that opened the post here.
It looks like a...
Yeah, okay, there we go.
Yeah!
Right, cows in, cows in.
Get in here!
Hold on.
Get in there.
There we go.
All right, I'm assuming we're going to have to shut the door or it might escape.
No, I think if it turns gold and then it's considered done because that chicken can jump out.
But I think the game is being rather kind to us.
No, no, no, no, no.
Now you stay here, Mr. Cow.
Yeah, open.
You're getting corralled whether you like it or not.
We need you for grazing.
Actually, I'm...
Oh, no!
I'm on...
This sounds bizarre.
I'm on sheep.
No, I'm on goat TikTok.
And now you might be like, what on earth is that?
This guy runs a grass-cutting business.
Amazing.
But wait, the chickens are escaping.
How?
Oh, no.
Oh, wait, they're climbing out of the things.
How can we prevent that?
We can.
Oh, there's no...
I mean, there are less animals on the field, but...
Yeah.
I'm not sure...
The pigs can push the gate open!
Oh, do we need to put the beehives?
Maybe.
I think so.
Yeah.
They don't perfectly run away, like, instantly, so...
Maybe...
Okay, so if the beehives aren't grabbable...
No, how strange.
Stay in here.
And then don't give up.
I mean, we're trying!
Like, you're making it...
This isn't the easiest...
I think I need to put hay bales in the way.
And that's what stops them.
Right, I'm gonna just shove hay bales everywhere.
Can you grab that hay bale?
Nope, the hay bale.
Oh, you know what?
Grab the trough.
Why not?
I'll just jump over the fence.
Okay, there you go.
No!
What?
Come here!
No way!
That just happened!
Right in front of me.
That just happened.
This little guy's a regular Houdini.
That was cheeky as any hen.
Like, get that...
Pig!
Get over here!
I'm gonna turn you into bacon at this rate.
Okay, and then I'm gonna put that hay bale on top
so we can escape.
Right, and then I'm gonna jump over...
Cause I can jump over, but they can't.
Right, and then I'm gonna grab this chicken
and then that's it done.
Oh, looks like we're still missing a couple.
Uh...
Mr. Chicken!
Stop it.
Or I'll make you KFC at this rate.
There's a pig over here!
Oh, no!
I got it with the shapes!
Oh, I didn't even...
Stay in there and don't come out.
Come here.
Can you be able to jump over with them?
Yeah!
Is this the last guy?
And maybe the last one.
It should?
Oh, there's still one.
There's still one left.
Isn't the turtle?
I don't...
I didn't see a pen for the turtle.
Okay, what are we missing?
Oh, there's a sheep's escape.
A sheep's escaped.
I see him.
If I can kangly get over.
See you!
Stop it!
Get over.
Oh, my God!
I don't know how we did that.
That was a very unique map.
I love the smell of animals in the morning.
Sorry, I forgot to share it again.
No, that's real!
What the heck?
I'm such a stinky streamer.
Not the game calling me out.
I'm so stinky all the time.
The game knows.
The game is enforcing you into the greasy girl stereotype.
Oh, literally.
Fair of one maxing.
Your fart level is now number two,
and I'm going to resist the obvious joke here.
Not the bees!
I don't know what the bee one was all about.
Maybe we...
I feel like if we...
Maybe if we slapped the bee hive, they would attack us.
I don't know.
Yeah, I'd believe that.
We're going to the farm next door.
What's that?
Right, I think this might be our cheeky last one,
so we need to make a count.
We're at the greatest of all time map, the goat map.
Looks like we didn't use enough animal puns or facts yet.
It's time for another animal move.
Get moving!
Let's go.
Be careful.
These goats think they are the greatest of all time.
Okay, so...
Oh, there's rams?
Do we need to worry about...
No, the rams aren't a part of it.
Okay, this does not look easy.
I'm not...
I'm getting nervous.
I'm getting shaky, okay?
Me too.
What are we supposed to do?
Oh my god, these rams are perfect!
Oh no!
And then where do you go?
Do we put the kettle over...
Right, first piggy, go.
No, go there and don't jump over.
Do you understand me?
Don't be a naughty piggy!
Oh, I see, okay.
Just everything, absolutely everything is thrown in here.
It looks like they don't jump out, which...
Oh, the rakes!
They can't attack you if you grab them.
Oh, the rams?
Yeah.
Oh, okay, okay.
Not bad.
Got it.
I'll hold on to this guy and keep it away from you.
Oh my god, yeah, literally.
I do need him to ram me.
Not ram me, but ram the fence.
Oh, he's missing!
No, you silly goober.
Come here.
Here.
Judge.
Aim for us.
Literally, aim for us.
Oh, damn it.
Oh, okay, we got one.
Well, the AI definitely stepped up to do that
because he was not aiming for there.
Thank you, AI.
I appreciate it, Game Devs.
Judge, out.
We're so thankful for you being so kind to us.
And this is why there's a moving out too,
because the devs were so smart to do that.
Yeah.
Ow!
There's a shovel there.
Wait, the shovel's there too?
Not just three?
Yeah.
I got hit by one before too.
Oh, yeah.
Yoink.
Can you...
Here.
Break this one, because we...
Mr. Ram.
Come here, come here, come here.
He literally walks away.
He couldn't give less.
Well, but...
He does not want...
He realized that ramming stuff is helpful to us
and immediately decided not to do it.
I've had enough.
Come on.
Okay.
More?
Oh my God, there's so many.
One wasn't enough.
Come here, come here, come here.
I actually can't reach him.
No!
Ow!
I was out of the way and then he spun and hit me anyway.
I'm like...
Can I smack him?
Yes.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
And then we need to do it one more time.
Smack.
Okay, if we smack him, it aggravates him.
Oh, I didn't realize.
Okay, wait, that's a slidey.
Okay, spank.
Come here, come here, come here.
Okay, we can spank him to annoy him.
No!
Ow!
Aw, freaking...
Wake up, Mr. Ram.
And then hit the...
I'll hold the door open.
No, Mr. Ram!
Where are you?
Come here!
Right, if you hold the door.
Spank.
No, spank.
All right, and then I am the red door.
Oh, yeah!
Come here, Mr. Cow.
I like how he's eating that hot dog as we draw.
That is so cute.
No, Mr. Ram, not now.
Some of us...
No, Mr. Sheep!
Ow!
I've made a horrible choice!
We've...
Mistakes were made.
Right, as long as the cow is getting in, we'll just toss the cow over next time.
If we get another one.
Okay, that's close.
That's fine.
All right, that...
Okay, that's close.
That's all that matters.
Okay, I can grab the chickens over here now.
You!
Get over here!
All accumulated in this corner.
Knock it off.
Some of us have a quota to meet.
Some of us have business to do.
Literally, trying to get business.
Is that everything broken?
No, you, Mr. Ram, come go there, get spanked, and then break this.
There.
Right, now go away.
Mr. Cow, you're coming with me.
I almost said speaking of Ram.
Google Chrome is stealing my Ram.
Honestly.
Failed that.
That's so real.
You need to download more dedicated wham.
Okay.
Yeah, I thought of a name that Chad can call me.
So, I saw some people saying Auntie, like Auntie Arisa.
I think Aunt Risa is fun.
Aunt Risa?
Yeah.
Aw, that's so sweet.
Mommy and Aunt Risa.
Ow!
Sorry.
Now Mr. Cow can come with me.
We'll just toss them over the wee fence thing because he is going to be a nightmare.
If we open up that patio thing again.
All right, grab, and then hold, and then we'll grab that one.
Why are all the chickens getting out of us and stop it?
Come here, let's just take them.
Put you together.
Okay.
Employee of the day.
We didn't even do anything.
I like how there's this crash spaceship to the right.
That's your first day complete.
We even had less complaints calls than usual.
That's because we're working outside on a farm.
This is the first day of the rest of our fart lives.
Exactly.
Should be smooth fart sailing from here.
Fart sailing, that sounds fun.
New game from SMG.
That's the name of the studio.
They're called SMG Studio, so this is good.
Oh my God.
Whatever happens, we're real farts, and no one can ever take that away from us.
Exactly.
Bring on Datu.
I'm ready for literally anything, no matter how weird, bizarre, or supernatural it is.
Good news, everyone.
It's getting late, but head back to HQ without breaking anything for a surprise.
Right, we'll go to HQ, see what's up, and then...
I think.
I mean, I think it's good.
Pass time.
Cows first.
Oh no, bad goat.
Don't let a goat stun you and deliver the goats.
We did deliver the goats.
We pulled the goats in the truck.
Ah, we're so sleepy.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I mean, I guess that doesn't...
Whoa, I've never been to the HQ at night before.
I hope this means we don't have to stop working once it gets dark.
Oh no.
Why sleep when we can move?
Quickly, now, unload the surprise from the truck.
Okay.
I found a way to make our lives easier.
It's called a computer.
Ah, it's a computer.
This baby will make smooth moves 90% more efficient, with 90% less employees.
Oh no.
Careful, it's one of a kind.
Okay, we're careful.
You don't know how hard it was to find this.
I feel like he's stolen it from somewhere.
All you need to know is that we'll make moving anything a breeze.
What could go wrong?
Move it into position and let's get going.
Oh my god.
We have platforms now.
This is...
Sorry, this game is so adorable.
I love this.
I don't know, can I go...
I think I can go up to four players as well.
And just the floor button.
Oh.
Okay, good.
Now to do some super high tech stuff.
Ah, yes, it's working.
I told them it'd be fine.
Eh?
Uh-oh.
Oh no.
We're unlocking the campaign mode.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh god, our boss got sucked in.
How are we going to make money if our boss is so young?
Oh no.
We arranged all the jobs for us.
We don't have to deal with anything.
What did you...
Why don't we get our paycheck?
I know, I was actually...
Did I still get my pension?
What happened to that?
What did you do?
You've stolen our inter...
No mention on Gateway.
And littered the multiverse with burn at your boxes.
Whoops.
Our badge.
You need to clean up this mess.
And save our boss?
Uh, sure.
That too, whatever.
Oh my god.
That's so cute.
You need to travel to each of these dimensions.
Oh, I skipped something there by accident.
Some are good.
Some aren't that good.
There's 12 reasonably skilled tech gnomes out there.
Bro, to help you repair the portal,
but you'll have to find them first.
You'd love.
They'll probably need it.
Hey, while they're doing that,
should we go get a hot dog or something?
I'm starving.
Oh my god.
What an adorable little game.
That...
So cute.
I literally can't get over that.
And we've just...
That's just gone past the tutorial mode, technically.
Because we've unlocked the campaign,
which is we need to save our boss.
From inter-dimensional moving around.
But I thoroughly enjoyed that.
That was fantastic.
That was lovely.
Thank you so, so much, Erisa, for hanging out with me.
That was a blast.
That was so good.
Thanks for having me.
For you little reeflings that are lurking in the shadows,
I have linked Erisa's Twitter.
She is debuting soon to end.
I don't have a date yet, but I've demanded.
I said, Erisa, as soon as you get a debut date,
you give it.
I want on my table.
I want on my table instantly.
Because we are very much likely going to do a watch along.
Or a readout.
It's on Twitch.
You use Twitch?
I'll be doing it on YouTube,
but then I'll be mostly streaming off of that.
Okay, okay.
If you do it on YouTube, then I can read out.
I can also redirect at a later point.
Or whatever.
But yes, already following her.
That's a good reefling.
That's what I want to see.
But yes, Erisa...
Erisa is the mastermind behind all the shorts on my channel.
She's absolutely fantastic.
Lovely debut.
Very soon to end.
All the assets are here.
And I'll leak anything as soon as she leaks it to me.
So don't you worry reeflings.
I'll keep you up to date.
I'll keep you up to date because I can't stop myself.
I just get so excited for future stuff for everyone.
Okay.
I can't help it.
I don't want to spoil the fun in that way.
Yes, thank you so, so much.
What I'm going to do, Erisa, is I'm going to leave the voice call.
And then I'm going to wrap it up with my reeflings.
And thank you so, so much for having a goof off with me on this game.
It's so cute.
Thanks for having me.
I had so much fun.
I had so much fun too.
Is there anything you want to say?
Or you want to plug yourself?
Even though I technically just did it.
Yeah.
I guess all my socials, same ad as my Twitter.
So you'll be able to find me.
Erisa and Anish everywhere.
And not to brag or anything.
But I'm pretty sure when Erisa starts streaming,
she's going to have the best shorts out there.
Just my bias opinion, but it's kind of true.
It's kind of true.
But yes, I will leave the call and wrap up the stream.
But thank you so, so much, Erisa.
That was an absolute blast.
Thank you for hanging out with me.
I really appreciate it.
And I'll talk to you later, okay?
Yeah.
Bye, Ani, Erisa.
Bye, Erisa, bye.
Oh, that was a hoot.
Hold on, let me send a little love heart.
Oh my gosh.
That was so cute.
What a lovely game as well.
That was a hoot and holler.
I'm so sorry, right?
Hold on, let me...
Thank you, tiny, spainy, anonymous,
and blatant, riefling, senpai.
My apologies.
I didn't mean to...
Ani, Erisa is gone.
Yum!
That was so fucking cute.
I thoroughly enjoyed that.
That was lovely.
I passed out, basically,
after my wee stream disease,
and then I woke up,
and we got into a voice call,
and I was just blabbing away
to her and being like,
oh, what's going on, you?
What's going on?
Are you squiddling me right now?
Brack...
Bratchy strikes.
That's it, you're getting
assigned a new gamertag by me, okay?
Your new gamertag
is Pikachu eating a hot pocket.
Okay, that's your new gamertag.
Bratchy strikes.
That's the only way
my brain is reading it.
I'm so sorry.
Thank you for becoming a member.
Please enjoy your emote as well.
I'm getting new emote soon too.
That was a hoot and holler.
I love that.
Please don't be surprised
if you see me missing
with Erisa again.
My redirect didn't work.
Shebe's playing Hayes!
I can redirect into her twice
technically, even though
I don't think it worked
the last stream for some reason.
My redirects have been
very broken as of late.
I'm not sure what
the dealio was that is.
I really am not...
causing a yep pass out for sure.
I didn't!
I promised I didn't do anything.
I'm literally going to go for a bath,
and then I'm going to get
my tripod out.
Enjoyed your walk after the first...
I didn't do anything!
I had a nap, okay?
I had a nap.
You should breath.
I've been buggy today.
Yeah, literally.
It does save for me redirecting
to Hayes part two
for Shebe cutting bin,
but whether or not
it's actually working
is a whole different story.
As for tomorrow's agendination,
we are playing a game
called Vermintite 2.
You can stream Snake Man.
I'm going to have a
throwaway steam account,
which I use for stream sniping.
So I will add you on it,
but I highly recommend
you do not add me
if it has your actual name
and details on it.
Please use gamer tags.
Please protect yourself.
Please be super safe.
And make...
make do...
If you need a gamer tag,
literally just call yourself
360 no scope default,
most generic thing you can.
Please be super safe,
because I will add you on steam.
And if you have your profile
set to like,
I can see your friends list
or whatever, you know,
I don't know, just be safe.
I will be deleting everyone
at the end of the stream.
If you do not play
Vermintite,
you do not have to get
the game to stream snake me.
We will be playing
plenty of other stream snake stuff.
What do I need to do
for Vermintite?
One, open your wallet.
Two, add me on steam,
but I'm going to make a steam account
for stream sniping things,
because I personally
really like stream sniping.
And it's what I want to do, okay?
I want to stream snake.
I'm not allowed to stream snake.
Why am I cut off?
I like stream sniping.
But yeah,
don't buy the game
if it's not for you,
just to stream snake.
We will play plenty of more accessible,
free to play shenanigans
and stuff that we'll get up to, okay?
The good news is,
Darktide has crossed me.
I know,
I'm Darktide.
I'm Vermintide.
Vermintide.
That's what we're doing.
But yeah,
that was a lovely, cosy stream.
I'm now going to do
inappropriate things,
wildly inappropriate things.
He he he he.
But yes,
I will redirect
into she be...
I'm not going to stall
because I do have to make up
to you,
my little reefling.
Is the wrist still in game?
I'm checking
if she's still in game with me.
I'm going to ask her to...
I'm honking the car.
This is me.
If she honks back,
I'll laugh.
No,
I think she's dead.
She's gone.
How long do you plan
to play Vermintide for?
I can probably do
like a solid
five hours of Vermintide.
It will probably be
my longest stream this week
on Ironic Clue.
I just adore stream sniping.
I do.
It just,
it makes me so happy
that I can play with you.
And
um,
oh my God,
Trani,
you're such a simp.
Yeah,
so what?
I'm a simp for reeflings.
What are you going to do about it?
I want to take your ink.
I want to play games with you.
And I want to have a good time.
Psh,
show me.
Show me.
So yes,
I will do the thing
where I write down
everyone's name
and then
if we've cycled through
everyone who is eligible to play,
we'll just start up
new lobbies, okay?
So
that's the plan.
That's the plan, Batman.
As reeflings are sent for you to a moment.
Maybe we should kiss you
or something.
I can't join,
sadly,
to protect Momay from the rats.
Reeflings?
Oh, don't worry.
Trani, let's do.
By the way,
Momay,
if you're on a new account,
you only have access
to the baby difficulty.
Oh, no.
I can't play legendary mode.
Oh, dear.
Oh, such as a tragedy,
little reefling.
Oh, no.
I have to play the easy mode.
So we get to play
and I don't get frustrated.
I think,
oh,
shucks.
I can't believe her.
Oh,
brass and brass and dictast.
I'll,
it's okay.
I am going to try
and play it a little bit
offline after I have
posted a few things
and done a few things.
Oh,
it's such a tragedy.
Mommy, no,
Mommy, don't go.
But if I go,
you get pictures.
I'm going to get a bath
to relax
and I'm going to get all
hairless
and smooth
and oiled up.
I mean,
other things follow
things.
After the pictures,
I'm going to wait
a whole 30 minutes.
Okay.
And whatever
is in my marshmallow.
Oh,
yes,
I'm going to redirect
into Sheepsters.
Please be
deliciously
kind to
our beloved rabbit.
As always,
and I will
see you
very
shortly.
Hmm.
Love you,
replay.
Okay.
You enjoy.
You're not even
let Riecklin shave you.
I don't know if your
technicals are too slimy
to trust with a razor blade.
I feel like
you've got stab resistance
because of the slime.
Mommy,
shave an ASMR.
I mean,
I'll record it
if you want to shave
an ASMR.
Yeah.
Okay.
Right.
I'm going to not stall
because I'm going to
relax in the bath.
As I said,
and then I'm a
like the coconut
and Elden Ring.
Let's get to it.
Okay.
Bye bye,
Evelyn.
Thank you for hanging.
Will there be an audio?
Yeah.
That's why
there's a 30 minute
wait
between the pictures.
And then I'll
make an audio.
And whatever
I get,
I get.
Thank you so much
for hanging.
I will see
you goofy gibberish
tomorrow on
Valentine's.
And then
we can have
lots of fun
on the old
Twitter too.
Okay.
Love you, Evelyn.
I'll see you very shortly.
Bye bye.
Thank you
for letting me
double stream as well.
Bye bye.
See you in a second.
Bye.